[Music]
foreign
so this is the third time we're doing
this it's the best part of the year the
season finale it is called the melee
Awards it's our annual awards show we
did it the first time I think improvd uh
or like pretty pretty close to it we did
it just like kind of on a whim people
loved it so we brought it back and now
we're bringing it back again and it's
basically it's our award so we do
categories like
Billy of the Year breakout company or
person our favorite unsexy business uh
our own best investments and our own
worst Investments things like that
um so I'm excited I already got the sort
of season finale Vibes and uh I'm
excited for this you want to say
anything did you look you you look like
you drive a white G-Wagon right now I
can't believe how fast you've gone from
Indian to Persian I look like my
mistress drives a white G-Wagon
you went from Dirty Indian to Alpha
Persian with just one jacket and that's
kind of amazing how that's happened I've
never sold a rug but I feel like I could
right now
yeah
and uh did you guys you guys let's see
Sam you didn't get the memo about
dressing up Andrew are you uh your Mikey
Blazer yeah you're blazered up did you
guys bring I'm wearing your cardigan bro
bro you always wear a cardigan you
always have like you know modern grandma
style
but I'm uh I'm I'm I'm at a guest place
you know I'm I'm on an Airbnb I got to
do what I got to do I didn't brand up I
didn't bring my Persian apparel I'm
sorry all right well guys cheers to a
great year uh a crazy year I have I
don't know what what's in everybody's
cup here so Sam you're you're a classic
Midwestern Cola kind of guy you probably
stay cold I don't you
no but I am drinking a Coke there's that
great map where it's like some people
say Pop Some people say Cola some people
say you know soda or something like that
I feel like you might be a pop guy uh
Andrew what you got in the cup
I've got a aeropressed coffee in a tiny
mug bro you just brought to you by you
just sponsored this whole pot just now
that was slick
um I have a uh
very frigid cold water with
fresh lemon juice inside maybe I'm
starting to cleanse I saw a great tweet
he goes I don't cleanse I clog and I
thought that's pretty that's pretty good
you're gonna choose cleanse I'm on a
cheese clog
um all right so cheers to you guys uh 20
million downloads this year for the
podcast which is I think six times
bigger than last year my or maybe four
or five five times I might have my math
on there but
I think YouTube's up 6X and the Pod is
up 4X or something like that
um big gear big year for us which is
which is fun and Andrew you were the
most frequent guest you're the most
favorite guest and so it is only right
to have you here all right so without
further Ado should we jump in to the
categories we're gonna go
uh I'll announce the category I think
and there we go kind of round robin
um last year we did it where we kind of
picked who had the best answer after
each one I don't know if you guys want
to do that or uh any any adjustments to
the format here
well I think by the way your order was a
little off so for example if we're going
to start with Billy of the year then
that has the next person because it's
also a the next category should be
craziest person of the year as well okay
okay well let's do it this way
um we'll take turns uh me and you say
I'm just picking categories and then uh
you can go whatever order you want so
okay let's start let's start with Billy
of the year uh so for those who don't
know we do the segment called Billy of
the week where we typically will feature
a billionaire or somebody who maybe is
not actually technically a billionaire
but they carry themselves with that
billionaire energy and uh somebody who's
just doing life in an interesting way so
Sam who is your Billy of the Year ah
mine's so boring so okay uh my boric
answer is Zuck because he's proven that
like he's actually pretty good all these
everyone else this year that's been in
his category has gone [__] insane
Bezos got a divorce elon's crazy all
Zuck does is box that's like his version
of crazy like he's turned out to be okay
so I would say he's probably like
emotionally stable huh
yeah he's done all right but if I had to
pick another one it would be this guy
named Brett Adcock Brett Adcock is this
guy I met about six months ago he
basically is only 34 to 36 years old
he's a young guy he made a lot of money
when he sold his company called veteri
for 100 million dollars then he created
veterans like a recruiting company he's
not sexy but then he created a flying
drone company that he took public called
Archer it was worth two or three billion
at its peak now he told me that he's uh
took roughly 200 million dollars of his
own money which I think was like the
majority of his liquid net worth other
than the house that he owns and he's
piled all of it into bootstrapping a new
robotic company called uh where they
make humanoids and that guy's pretty
[__] insane and I love crazy people
like that that's a great one Andrew who
you got Billy of the year
so my mine is actually a MFM guest
Palmer lucky
um I feel like you know it's a little
obvious but I feel like um you see so
many of these billionaires who they make
all this money and then they get very
focused on PR and they're very safe and
they won't put their money where their
mouth is and what I loved about him is
that a he's actually taking his own
capital and investing it in and drill
and doing something that is actually
important in the world or what he deems
important and he actually just like
calls people out like he's honest he's
not a politician and I think most of
these billionaires you talk to they are
very political they have a PR team he
obviously does not I thought that was so
awesome when he went to the uh what is
it the all-in conference and just
roasted calcamus for like an hour
um so yeah mad respect I think he's
awesome and I thought that was one of
the best interviews of the year that's a
great one
um I love that one I thought I
considered Palmer lucky as well I
decided to go with somebody a little
more under the radar not a billy not a
billionaire but somebody who lives like
I think a billionaire should so it's
this guy who came to Camp MFM which was
our kind of like private retreat of 20
or 30 badass people that we did who Al
no Syed Saeed said so Saeed is a guy I
didn't know much about you had mentioned
him before I didn't I never met him
he might be a billionaire he might be
but uh but it doesn't matter he lives
like one so when we met him at the camp
I was like so what do you do he first of
all he just had the most chill energy he
was not stressed he was not worried he
was not seeking attention he was he had
none of those small boy traits and
instead he was relaxed he was having fun
he was asking people questions and I
asked him I said so what do you what do
you do and he's like well you know I and
he he started to explain and somebody
else cut him off and was like let me
brag for you for a second here so what
Syed owns is basically the largest
collection of Wordpress websites and
tools so if you search for WordPress
like you know WordPress powers like 30
or 40 of all internet websites and so
people are often searching how do I do
this on my WordPress site
you'll land typically on one of his
websites like wpbeginner or WP engine or
whatever and from there it'll say well
if you want to capture emails of people
who come in using Wordpress like a email
capture pop-up use optinmonster owned by
also Saeed and so he basically has the
landing spot where people come he's got
the number one search rankings then he
owns the tools that he refers and so he
turned his random curious traffic into
SAS subscribers it basically built an
Empire he's telling us about the gas
stations he owns and all the other crazy
stuff he does with his money and his
work style was was one that I envy he's
like well
here's my month the last week of the
month I do all my meetings with the
operators of my businesses I was like so
what do you do the other three weeks and
he's like one egg one to one and a half
weeks we travel so we just go to Costa
Rica then we go to Egypt then we go
wherever like me my family we just love
to travel
and then I read and I just chill out and
I think uh the other the other week and
a half I play with my son a lot we play
basketball
and I was like wow this guy is
dominating his business Niche but he's
also
checking the Box on family he's checking
the Box on travel he's got it going on
so I was really impressed by Syed this
he also very very uh giving too he he
gives away a lot of money too yeah
amazing guy so uh so he's mine that's uh
all right so those are the billies of
the year I I'll just put it out there I
think Palmer was the right answer what
do you think Sam
I agree Palmer was the right answer
you're if you haven't seen the clip of
him going to Jason calacanus's
conference like going to someone's
birthday party and roasting them uh that
was epic
Andrew did you hear on our pod when we
asked Palmer if you could kick Jason's
ass
yeah when he was talking about his scare
his like how tall he was he goes yeah he
was like well you know if you look at
the physics of this I I forget exactly
how he explained it but he was like a
very engineer he goes like six one yeah
he said something like that like it it
was pretty funny all right let's go to
the next category Sam you can pick one
um let's talk about the biggest L we
each took this year
okay Andrew you go first Adrian by the
way this category the biggest l so it's
the biggest loss you took but it can be
it doesn't have to be like a big serious
thing it's just it's just a loss that
you put in the in the Lost column
however big or small it was in your life
yeah so I read this book about 15 years
ago by this guy ramit Sethi uh he's got
a website I will teach you to be rich
and he's got a book called I will teach
you to be rich and at the time I knew
absolutely nothing about personal
finance or Finance at all and he had
this really great section where he says
people think they need to save money on
lattes what they actually need to save
money on is percentages and so he's
talking about interest rates on credit
cards interest rates on mortgage uh fees
and real estate transactions like the
difference between two percent and 2.5
percent is like twenty thousand dollars
and people don't think about that he
says uh he goes don't worry about three
dollar problems worry about worry about
thirty thousand dollar problems exactly
so I had one of those
um so you know maybe like two episodes
of you know a couple interviewers ago I
talked about
um you know interest rates and the risks
there and this was very top of mind
because we had a piece of debt in the
company that uh I wanted to lock in the
interest rate on one and so we were
going to buy all these Hedges and in
order to do that I had to sign all these
documents and I'm kind of lazy I hate
signing documents and so these documents
were sitting in our office and I was
like oh I'll do it tomorrow I'll do it
tomorrow I kept putting it off and then
finally I signed it and I realized that
between the time that I it was sitting
there for a week and in that week the
interest rate went up by like one
percent and that represented like five
hundred thousand dollars or something
insane and so just me being lazy and not
signing that document and not thinking
in percentages cost me like 500 Grand
that's a great one
um this year I met a guy who had an app
called intro it's a great app and I
agreed to do it because he was like hey
come try this
and I did and it was one of the big
bigger mistakes of the year that I made
so basically I'm on this app called
intro where for a little while people
could you you were bragging about how
you were crushing it on intro how is
this the L that's such a weak move on my
part to do it so this app I got on there
because I was like oh you know and
honestly it's fun it is quite fun to use
it's fun to like meet new people but
people pay me for my time and it's quite
addicting because it's real you can make
a substantial amount of money doing that
but if I'm supposed to be such a big
swing of dick if I'm supposed to be a
hot shot like I want to be I shouldn't
be selling my time or at least I
shouldn't be selling my time and keeping
the money I should just give it away and
it was that was a big uh that was a weak
move on my part to uh be selling my time
and I regret doing that that's a that's
a great one I was making fun of you for
that and uh and then I was also kind of
like wait should I be doing that that is
a lot of money don't sell your time
don't sell your time
such short-term thinking and you know
who really changed my opinion of it who
actually could be Billy the year what's
the guy Brian Johnson Brian Johnson from
um uh Braintree he like kind of like
didn't mean to do it but he like was
razzmy on using it and I was like you're
right what did I say that wasn't he was
telling us well he told the story he
didn't he wasn't directing it towards me
but he told the story about how he was
like instead of like getting this job
like I should just put more effort into
my company so then in three years this
won't even be a problem instead of right
now I could just make this money that
could temporary fix this no I should go
for the long-term fix and make it so
like I don't even have to budget ever
again yeah I see a lot of so I think
like all three of us kind of probably
grew up not having a ton of money
um and really really valuing like every
dollar right so like I remember
um you know a thousand dollars was like
a crazy amount of money to me because I
could buy an iMac and if I bought an
iMac then I could have one of my staff
do all this work and I could make like
twenty thousand dollars from it and so I
feel like I still if I I'm not careful I
think in those terms and when someone
comes along and offers you a thousand
dollars an hour it's like completely
insane as an opportunity or like three
grand an hour or four grand for an hour
it is crazy it's amazing but you get and
I know all these people that are like I
know guys that are worth 50 million
dollars and they still manage their own
Airbnb bookings and they'll be like oh
sweet I tweaked this I made an extra 300
in cleaning fees or whatever and I
always think like you guys used a quote
before but it's like you're playing
you're playing a pennies or sorry you're
you're saving pennies in a dollars game
like it's just ridiculous yeah that's uh
yeah but some people enjoy that like
Nathan Barry uh Nathan Berry owns
convertkit he's probably worth 200 plus
million dollars based off the valuation
convertkit and he's still I'll be with
him and applaud his phone and he's like
messaging Airbnb guests I'm like why are
you doing this he goes I love it and so
in that case I'm like all right cool I
don't like taking intro calls
necessarily sometimes I do but uh yeah
yeah there's a there's a good test I
remember I talked to this guy when we
got acquired by twitch I talked to a guy
who had been acquired by twitch three
years ago and I was like yo let's get
lunch so we go out for lunch and I'm
like um you know he's like yeah you're
gonna love it you know yeah but watch
out for this he's like giving me a bunch
of tips I'm like okay great
um let me give you a tip real quick uh
yeah I just got here but let me give you
a tip I was like why are you still here
and he's like oh dude um I really like
my job actually you know I I didn't
think I would stay here but I really
like it you know it's it's fun I just
blah blah he tells you tell me how great
it is but I had kind of seen him in a
couple meetings at this point and I was
like these meetings aren't fun so like
you know I don't know what you're doing
the other hours a day but I saw you for
like half a day last week and that that
didn't seem fun at all
um I said okay well maybe it is fun but
let me just ask you something
um you made you know he probably made
like 10 20 million dollars on sale I
said uh I said you don't need this job
but uh but but you're not at the point
where for you you're just gonna stop
working all together blah blah
and I said uh I said if you had 100
million dollars in the bank
like literally like if I open up your
bank account right now is 100 million
dollars just sitting there would you
come into work tomorrow like would you
would you
would you do this just for fun because
at that point you know what you're
making here every year is a rounding
error it's a you you just make that in
in an interest uh if you were uh if you
had 100 million dollars sitting there
he's like well no then I would go do XYZ
and I was like okay cool so this as long
as we're just being honest like I'm not
saying you're miserable here I agree but
the stories we tell ourselves in order
to justify doing something that we're
actually doing for the money but we
don't want to say we're doing it for the
money we want to say we're doing it for
all these other reasons there's a very
simple test imagine you had all the
money would you still do this thing and
like but the other the other the
dangerous thing about that logic so Ryan
holiday has this great daily stoic
podcast and re recently he had um a
excerpt from Stephen pressfield's book
he's got all these books about kind of
discovering your thing and your Mastery
and art and all this kind of stuff and
he talks about how people get addicted
to patterns so people can be addicted to
um love they they can be addicted to
money they could be addicted to you know
any almost anything and the question I
always ask myself is I might love
designing the website or I might love
going into the Shopify stats and seeing
the sales or doing the Airbnb management
but is that just me addicted to those
dopamine hits distracting myself from my
greater purpose right from doing
something where I have Mastery that's
new am I just going back to the same
thing right like you guys know the joy
there's this amazing confirmation bias
Joy of reading a book and hearing
something you already know confirmed
over and over and over again I'll do
this with like uh value investing books
right and I'll go oh I already know that
I do that I feel good right that's
actually a waste of time and so that's
the flip side of it the other one is uh
my buddy told me this when I when I'd
been working on my startup for six or
seven years and he was like
he's like he told me he's like you know
I just don't get what you're doing I was
like well what do you mean I can explain
it and he's like no not the logic of it
he's like I just feel like let me ask
you a question if this all went away
is this what you would sign up to go do
like would you basically like like take
the example of the guy I was talking to
if you got if you weren't doing this job
is it would you just apply for this job
here
no you would go do something completely
different like you're here because you
got Acquired and then you're here and
now fast forward three or four years
later you're still here doing the same
job but if I took this job away you
would never go to a job posting and
apply for this job and he's and so he
was explaining that he's like you know
inertia is just a [__] he's like
whatever your an object in motion will
stay in motion whatever you're doing
you're probably most likely you're doing
it because you were already doing it not
because you think it's the thing you
actually should do in most cases and so
you got to be really aware of that all
right
um so what's yours okay so uh wait what
is the category even what are we in your
biggest l oh my biggest L okay I have
one that's sort of like yours I was
chasing pennies in a dollar game so
I recently moved and uh your boy rents
I'm a renter and so I moved from one
rental to another a new house and I was
like oh I love this I could just like
move whenever I want don't have to worry
about anything just call the movers I
broke my lease I just moved but um my
landlord came in and uh first you know
did a walk through of the place when I
was there
you know we talked about his you know
his family his history in this house
shook hands in the garage said you know
it's been nice having you all right see
you later you know don't worry about all
the stuff everything looks fine
three weeks later he hits me with like a
20 or 30 000 bill and um at least twenty
thousand he gets me with the extra
twenty thousand dollar bill on the move
out for like you know
scratches and like you know stuff like
with he right no he was not right it was
and he had he's a lawyer so he had baked
into the lease that like hey
anything that's associated with the move
out is your cost like for example if I
fly to California to observe the move
out you have to pay for my flights my
hotels my food my this my like there's a
[__] in there that was like not like I
didn't damage the property it was just
like extra stuff but he had put it in
the lease I had signed the lease because
like you know like Andrew I don't really
I
I don't really read it or if I read it
I'm not going to read what are words
yeah it's like uh you know I'm
optimistic at the beginning of things
I'm like this is gonna go great he's
gonna be a chill dude just like I would
be well he's never gonna hold me to any
of these things and like sure enough he
held me to the letter of the law and
every single thing and so he so I decide
to do something that we talked about on
this uh on this podcast I decided to
take him to Petty court and so a lawyer
a guy who listened to the Pod who's a
lawyer reaches out he's like yo I heard
about the landlord thing I'm ready to
fight to the death on this for free and
I was like let's do this and so in my
head I was like I'm gonna fight this 20
grand got this lawyer now he's got Troy
you know he's a great dude
um got to know him a little bit through
this process but we try fighting back we
and the problem is I'm going against an
87 year old retired lawyer who's got
nothing not my time on his hands he this
is probably the biggest thrill he's had
in 37 years to fight and be and you know
like look up every California statute
and he sends me these packets of like 47
documents he sends me CD-ROMs full of
photos of the property I'm like dude I
don't have a CD player to put this in
what about how am I supposed to see
these photos and he's just sending me
letter after letter and he's
I took a guy to Petty Court
who is like the king of petty court and
in the end I end up paying the full
amount just by saying eff it and I'm
like because I'm like dude I'm wasting
my time I'm wasting this lawyer's time I
might say this old guy's time but he's
got infinite time and uh he is built for
this whereas I should have just wrote
this 20K check and just moved on with my
life five weeks ago and I knew it
because at night
when before I was going to sleep I was
up I was like oh [__] I didn't respond
to that [__] subpoena he sent me
basically this like giant package of
letters I was like okay I'm gonna call
him I'm gonna say this he's gonna say
that I was like imagining this whole
debate in my head I was like dude what a
waste of mental space and once I finally
had that realization that I was playing
a small boy game by losing my mental
like my mental space in my head that
could be done used on productive things
in order to be in petticort I wrote the
check and I moved on with my life dude I
think it's worth fighting those things
by the way no no it's 100 dude
going to war for the sake of war is
worth it I had the Sam on my shoulder
and I had the Andrew on my shoulder and
I listened to the salmon I should have
never listened to the Sam I wasted four
weeks of my life that's like you're
you're like a bull in a china shop and
there's this tiny little fly buzzing on
you and you just have to ignore it
there's a great quote on this that
someone said to me once when I was going
through something similar and the guy
said Never Wrestle a pig you'll both get
dirty but the pig will enjoy it yeah
that is exactly there's no problem I'm
the pig here I'm the pig here
what I I had Sean I had the you know my
situation yeah I had something like this
go on this year too and I texted Andrew
I go what do I do and he said the same
thing he goes don't wrestle with pigs or
whatever this [__] biblical [__] and
I bought into it and it eats me it eats
me every night that someone that someone
got someone I got got you there's what's
the Charlie Munger calls it um the rats
and The Granary right if you own a
granary you have a big Warehouse full of
grain there's gonna be rats you can keep
killing them over and over again but
they're gonna always come back and it's
better to just accept that there's rats
out there
said we got rats at your Granary bro
yeah
okay let's go to the next one okay cool
um all right let's go to the next
category let's do we're gonna do
breakout company which is sort of the
sexy one and then let's do the unsexy
business of the year so we'll do we'll
do both first let's do the uh the
breakout company of the year uh Andrew
you want to go first
yeah I mean this is so obvious but I and
I I came up with a few others but I just
I feel like we both want to say the same
obvious thing where everyone's gonna say
the same eye open AI open AI gpt3 is
shocking I think this is like a
watershed moment and uh I there's
nothing else I haven't seen anything
like this in probably 10 years
I have two words for you guys that that
will change your opinion yeah liver King
what this guy called his shot man that's
the trooper you're gonna tell me that
that dude when you have Elon Musk and
Sam Altman and 10 billion dollars that's
not a breakout company that's not a
breakout that's just that's a company
that they are who we thought they were
they did exactly what we thought they
were gonna do that that doesn't count as
a breakup you're saying you expected you
expected like when I I remember a friend
of mine called me about a month before
they released the chat and was like oh
my God it's amazing and I kind of rolled
my eyes you know I didn't wasn't super
excited about it but I have not seen
anything this crazy in a very long time
I mean obviously Dolly and stuff is
insane too but the chat it's just nuts
I've actually stopped using Google a lot
of the time and started using the chat
do well look they you took the nerdiest
of nerds the smartest guys on Earth and
who gave them 10 billion dollars and he
locked him in a room for six years yeah
but like if you knew their friends if it
was 1945 and you're like what's the
breakout project of the year and I'm
like it's the Manhattan Project and
you're like oh well this got billions of
dollars and whatever it's still [__]
crazy they made a nuclear bomb it's
crazy this is like a nuclear bomb moment
it's just like my expectations they met
my expectations like If This Were
if this were like uh if this was like a
second grade report report card it would
definitely be like met expectations
there would not be there would not be
like yeah yeah this is not an exceed
I kind of felt like it was a goofy
project I was like oh you know Google
Apple all these other people they're
gonna do this for you know they have a
huge incentive profit incentive these
guys are going like non-profit when they
first started and it's kind of like all
about openness and whatever it's morphed
into something that I didn't expect and
I certainly didn't expect it to do as
well as it did given all the star power
I think often think about like super
groups super groups are usually not that
good it was like a super group yeah I
mean the Avengers worked out but yeah I
feel you I I feel you I mean like in
music so Sam yours your your breakout
person or company is liver King
not AI
I mean yeah we're Andrew Tate but yeah
one of those guys we did an episode
where we detailed the leaked emails from
the liver King where he's like yo I'm
gonna take a bunch of steroids I'm gonna
build this brand and then I'm gonna sell
like 100 million dollars worth of
products that's what I'm gonna do and
then he did it so
that's so much more dope all right let
me merge the tune so Sam you like the
call your shotness Andrew you're like
wow open at my Sam Altman you guys have
done something magical I'm gonna give
you a called shot that I think is kind
of unbelievable to be honest with you
okay so
Paul Graham is going to win my award
here for calling it they call your shot
moment so back in 2009 Paul Graham wrote
a blog post so this is now what like 13
years ago or something like that
Paul Graham writes a blog post it's
called if you go to paulgram.com Five
Founders the number five in the founders
he says inc.com recently asked me oh
yeah my most interesting Founders are
the last 30 years he goes how do you
decide who's interesting I think it's
influence you know who are the five have
influenced me the most who do I use as
examples when I'm talking to companies
that I'm funding who do I find myself
quoting a lot and it's everybody you
would expect it's Steve Jobs is number
one he's got Larry and Sergey from
Google he's got like his buddy but Paul
bukite who uh invented Gmail and also
wrote the first prototype for AdSense
and gave Google the Mantra of don't be
evil okay everything's expected so far
and number five he says Sam Altman hey
guys I was told I shouldn't mention who
at the time by the way was 22 I think
right yeah exactly at the time he's
probably 21 or 22 years old and he was
wearing he was wearing double pop neon
colors with Steve Jobs exactly very
embarrassing put up a photo of him doing
this uh uh announcement at the at the
Apple conference where he's wearing a
double Polo neon popped collar uh it's
it's really incredible
you wouldn't think that that guy's gonna
rule the world but but Paul Graham knew
that he would so he's here's what he
wrote about Sam Alvin back in 2009 he
goes I shouldn't mention a YC founder
um but Sam Altman cannot be stopped by
flimsy rules if he wants to be on this
list he is going to be honestly Sam is
along with Steve Jobs the founder I
refer to most when I'm advising startups
on question of design I asked what would
Steve do but on a question of strategy
or ambition I ask what would samma do uh
when when I learned meeting Sama is that
the doctrine applies the doctrine of the
elect applies to Startup it applies in a
way that that it applies way less than
most people think startup investing is
not about picking winners you think
might win a horse race because there are
a few people with such force of will
that they are going to get whatever they
want and now you fast forward 13 years
the guy you know basically creates this
you know what's going to be a multi
probably a multi-hundred billion dollar
Company open Ai and brings you know one
of the most magical
technical like magical technology
experiences which is if you're if you're
using dolly or gpt3 he created and he
wasn't even that successful back then by
the way I don't think he had I think he
I think he had sold a company but he
sold it was less than they raised I
don't think he sold it even at that
point so let me see when it was called
loot yeah it was loot um and I think
they made they sold it for about 43
million dollars he sold it three years
later so this was he was at the
beginning of loot he sold it for 43
million and uh and I think and I I
remember reading about the sale there
were some there's some interesting stuff
about how he uh like they sold it for
less than it than it was funded for
right which is like you know considered
an L uh but he but he sold it in a way
that he was able to pocket a few million
bucks he then invested in Airbnb right
away and was the first seed investor in
Airbnb he's got this like you know he
went on kind of an epic run post that
um yeah he's a crazy guy I think that's
uh that's got to be the breakout is I
agree maybe Sam Altman this time can
beat the liver King but it's close we
could all agree you know tomato tomato
the most impressive thing about liver
King is he's not a good looking dude
like some of these guys you see in their
influencers and they're like super
jacked and handsome he's not a good
looking he's my example when I say I I
told sahil Bloom this because saho Bloom
is like the good looking version of me I
was like hey if I can't be good looking
I'm gonna be interesting looking and uh
that's what the liver King did he's not
good looking but he decided to be really
[__] interesting looking and that
works just as well uh I then we'll have
to go with Sam Altman gets it this time
all right let's do unsexy business
um oh dude I didn't even know what you
meant by that well you go first an
unsexy business is like when we do our
our blue collie uh blue collar Billy of
the week what do we call this [__] the
blue collar side hustle uh it's like a
business that's not artificial
intelligence or flying cars or whatever
it's just like
a boring unsexy business how are you
confused by this this is like the
premise of our podcast but I don't know
all right well
what podcast uh so what's yours all
right I'm gonna go with um I could go
with uh egg cartons but I think I've
kind of beat that one to death the egg
cartons.com if you haven't heard me rant
about that go look up that episode that
is honestly that is the most remarkable
one this woman Sarah Moore but if not
that I'm gonna go with one we haven't
talked about that much on here it's
called Aunt Flo have you heard of this
business
no so what are you saying the word ant I
like ant
I'm saying flow yeah ant flow okay all
right you could say it your way sorry I
just wanted to make sure that this the
it's the word that we're using okay yeah
so I am flow so amp flow is a business
that is basically
um
it's period products I don't know how
I'm supposed to say this but for uh it's
period products so basically you go to a
public restroom inside of any University
a stadium whatever
in the women's restroom they uh should
have and now in many states they are
mandating that you have to have you know
tampons pads products for women and so
um normally these were coming in a Dusty
raggedy container uh with like really
poor hygiene you gotta like open the
thing and everyone's like trying to use
toilet paper to like touch the thing to
open it and it's like really gross I
mean this is like you know there's like
literally like blood on these products
so it's not not like a very it's not not
something that you want to touch it's
not a sexy experience and what she did
was she brought a sexy experience to a
very unsexy industry so if you go look
at their dispensers they basically made
like the Tesla of of dispensers and they
install it on the wall it's got this
great brand she's this great founder and
they are just cleaning up so they are
getting conscious with universities with
what and these are multi-year contracts
it's installed on the wall this thing is
never going to get changed it's gonna be
no churn is my prediction and it's sort
of like they installed a dispenser and
then they have to buy the products as
they as they're used or as they run out
and um and she calls herself the CEO the
chief estrogen officer she's just gone
all in on like building this company as
a woman-led company that's like making
this one kind of crappy experience
better and I asked her I was like did
you invest in this yeah I was like I've
never been in a woman's restroom before
uh what's the current like who's the
incumbent who are you competing against
and she's like literally it's a guy
named like a brand called Bob and Rick
and like Bob and Rick's dispensers are
like the thing and you know it's this
terrible experience and we're making it
better and so they're at like you know
they're definitely at a sort of like
high seven figures uh uh run rate where
they have all these great contracts and
they you know they're they're the
official dispenser for all the Apple
Stores and for like you know the whole
state of you know I don't know Utah or
whatever some State that's like mandated
this can happen and I think once one
state does it all these states are gonna
do it so I think they're very well
positioned to take a very boring Niche
and build a pretty badass business and
she's a teal fellow only 25 years old
yeah air coder I think her name is
that's right that's a good one do you
have one Andrew
yeah okay so
um hotels are constantly trying to save
money especially chains and I don't know
if you've ever gone to like a hotel
chain you'll notice that on the wall if
it's like a cheaper one they'll have
like dispensers for shampoo and soap and
it's all refillable right so the idea is
like you used to go to a hotel and
there'd be a bar of soap in a box and
you open the bar of soap and you use it
to clean your ass and then they have to
throw it away right so um it's a huge
waste they're constantly throwing money
away and so hotels have moved to these
refillable things but one thing that
um they can't do is toilet paper so when
you go and there's a full roll of toilet
paper and you use some of it you know no
one wants to go into a hotel and be like
oh what the heck there's like a little
bit of toilet paper left there's
obviously someone just here who used it
and so there's someone I just heard
about this business it hasn't launched
yet but I thought it was fascinating
basically it's a dispenser for toilet
paper so it's on it actually embeds in
the wall all and you basically pull out
almost like you would Kleenex perfectly
portion toilet paper and I don't think
this would necessarily work at like a
Four Seasons or a high-end place but
certainly for like a Marriott or a
Hilton I think they could save tons of
money so I thought that was just
incredibly boring and quite interesting
that's a great one all right that's a
good one there was one that got big
doing that with uh with the shampoo
bottles back in the day they would take
the
once used shampoo bottle and they would
recycle it basically and they were just
like hey Hotel will pay you nothing for
it but we'll come collect it for you
we'll just take it off your hands
because you're just this is just trash
for you and they created so have you
guys invested in any boring businesses
like I you know I give Nick Huber a
little bit of money I think you did yeah
what else what other boring stuff have
you guys done uh I'm in enduring so they
buy you know the same kind of boring
businesses that's kind of tech I mean
like I mean like brick and mortar
uh development of real estate like
Townhomes I feel like we it's weird
because I feel like half of what we talk
about on this podcast is like these
Boring Brick and Mortar businesses and
yet we like and we like fetishize them
we don't own that many of them like
yeah I own a uh an air uh air ambulance
business
um I you know I own a deli and bakery a
bunch of kind of restaurants and that
kind of stuff wait what the but I want
to get your ambulance oh like
helicopters ambulance so if you're like
in Mexico and you need to be brought
home and you've you've had a surgery or
something we facilitate that
um it's a very good business but I
really want more of those things have
you guys ever thought about like
starting like a fund around that or
something because I feel like it's a lot
of words
yeah I like to visit I don't really live
there
we don't have to operate you don't have
to operate us just invest in all these
cash flowing boring businesses I I
whenever people talk about that I'm like
where do you find that like like you're
going to eBay like where do you like
where do you find this air ambulance
thing you know what I mean
yeah it was like we had to we met
someone through a friend of a friend
it's always like someone's dad right
it's like oh you know his his dad wants
to retire and the kids don't want the
business or something like that or these
things happen at the golf course
yeah I don't know yeah I should be doing
that I I think I got like really Tech
brainwashed because I basically
I started a sushi restaurant then I
moved to Australia and did like a
biotech thing but then I moved to
Silicon Valley when I was 24 and I was
like basically I just got like really
deep in the Silicon Valley kind of ethos
and game and that was my that's my
network and that's my my skills were
around internet companies
and so I think it was kind of the right
move to go deep there and try to like
win in that World
um because I think you don't have to win
in all games so like you know I have a
fun to do startup investing like if I do
good with if I do great with startup
investing I'll do great I don't really
need to also do great with a very
different style of investing so I think
I'm curious about it but
um you know do I want to like sort of
restart the learning curve in a new way
but one you know you guys have this
crazy advantage of you know I think your
your rolling fund as well because of the
podcast right so if you guys go on and
you say hey who has a Granddad or a
father or a mother who owns this family
business that wants to sell I feel like
you'd get mobbed there's something let's
see all right Sean at seanpuri.com all
those leads can go to me then if you
guys don't want let's let's see what
comes in I'll share all the interesting
I'll filter all the interesting ones uh
for you Andrew so Sean at seanpuri.com
email me your your dad your granddad
your uncle's business that we could
either take like a minority stake or
maybe he's looking to retire itself
let's see let's see what we got
um
okay so those are the ones
um dude you know I I did it but I I was
reading about coffeezilla going deep on
Andrew Tate's thing do you guys know how
Andrew Tate makes money I do but go
ahead he basically
he has this well okay fine you got that
smug look on your face
it's like a cam girl's business right
like it's a definition of a sexy person
no no the real way to make money is yeah
he's got this [__] Discord that's 50
a month in order to like join and
there's like channels on like
copywriting it's basically just the same
[__] that you and I Sean have done like
screwing around except do you know how
big it is it's like tens of 150 million
yeah no no no no no no like a million
members oh wow like we're talking nine
figures in revenue and coffee Zilla like
did it he's like look here's all the
members if you multiply that by 50 and
then you can even add a discount to it
it's like we're talking about north of
100 million in revenue and it's just a
Discord with voluntary with volunteer
community like chairs like Community
leads freaking crazy and uh I considered
saying for breakout person but I you
know he's obviously pretty controversial
so I didn't want to like I'm the
breakout is I've never seen somebody go
from nobody to everywhere all the time
in your face the way this guy has like
he built a crazy in like seven months or
something like that like had you ever
heard this word before Andrew Tate last
year like no no I think he was the most
Googled person on Earth this year
that's crazy to me is that crazy and he
says it and when he when he does his
interviews he goes he goes Mr Beast has
to spend five million dollars and blow
up blow up a bus in order to get 10
million views I said I said I just talk
yeah
and it's true it's true the guy's way of
speaking and the the things he says are
so compelling and then he built this
viral engine where his all hustles
University is is basically yo post cut
cut up clips of Tate everywhere and then
go comment and basically in the comments
Revere me and that's how you know and
then everybody who signs up for the
professor University you're gonna make
money doing that like that's basically
the core job is like go promote me
um it's crazy it's insane it is crazy
it's a multi-level marketing scheme just
promoting him he is the product
it's wild all right so what's uh do we
vote on that one or just move to a
different topic uh yeah vote
okay let's do our best investment so the
best investment you made and then we're
gonna do worst investment also so let's
start with uh let's start with best
investment let's go Sam what was the
best investment you made 2022
financially [__] none this year was
in terms of money this was horrible uh
the two best uh Investments I made were
getting Fitness coaches so nutritionists
and and like a lifting coach a fitness
coach and then also this pod this is
like the first time Sean this year where
like and this is actually one of my most
proud moments where I've been walking
around and I get noticed maybe one to
three times a day and this is the first
time that I'm like oh wow Sean the work
that you and I have done over four or
five hundred episodes it's like properly
paid off yeah so that's this part is
this this year it felt different has it
ever has ever been annoying or yeah one
time like it's there's been multiple
times where Sarah and I are having like
a serious conversation or we're arguing
or we're having like a contentious
conversation and someone pops up and
like you gotta like like oh hey yeah hi
hi yeah you gotta like turn it on and
that kind of sucks it's like you know
like when you and your wife get in a
fight but then you got to get in the car
together to go to like your friend's
house for dinner and you gotta put on
like the performance of the century
that's kind of like how it feels
sometimes there's a there's a uh what's
her name from The Hunger Games Jennifer
Lawrence her name Lawrence she talked
about how she can be nice to a thousand
people but if one time she's fighting
with her boyfriend and she's kind of a
[__] to somebody they'll go on Reddit
and post about it and she feels like you
basically always have to be that person
and it's only a matter of time until you
snap knowing you it's only a matter of
time one time we are at um you know
we're we're exploring the pregnancy
thing this year and one time we were at
the baby baby doctors and someone in the
waiting room said something to me and uh
I was I was I didn't I was rude
apology there
all right I'll do a quick one okay so
best financial investment I invest in
this company called triple will that's
basically like a uh it's a tool for
Shopify store owner so it helps you
like see your dashboard and uh make sure
your ads are working well and they have
like a bunch of different features I
invest in this thing because I I was
like oh I like this I want to use this
for my Ecom store maybe I should just
invest in it really didn't think this
was gonna I thought if and I did this by
the way I took my portfolio and I ranked
like what do I think are going to be the
breakouts and what do I think are least
likely to be the breakouts because I I
suspected I might be surprised I was
very surprised so us I think our 75 000
investment in triple whale is currently
worth 3.3 million and so uh that's been
the the biggest breakout from the fund
so far and it's would have been one of
the five that I did not guess would be
this explosive rocket ship because like
that's just not how I thought about it
back then like when I saw it it looked
like this cool Analytics tool for Ecom
you know Shopify stores I don't know how
big that is I don't know how fast it'll
grow it's been insane so that's my
financial one and then I'll also say
um we did Camp MFM and that was an
amazing investment I'll tell you a
little little story about it so we did
this camp
20 30 people we go to North Carolina and
we fly in this NBA trainer so we pay for
his kind of him and his buddy like
they're they're uh fights at hotels or
whatever we rent these airbnbs we do the
camp it's great everybody chipped in I
think like a thousand bucks or 1500
bucks two grand or something yeah I
thought I thought that would cover the
cost didn't quite cover it I think we're
in the whole like 15 grand or something
like that no problem uh amazing
experience just for the basketball all
the fun meeting people all that good
stuff but something kind of crazy
happened
um we tweeted out that we were hanging
with Mr Beast or something like that or
that uh that maybe the Pod we recorded
with Mr Beast
and a guy saw that started following Ben
Levy Ben Levy then checks out this guy's
profile
um oh this guy's in the crypto space
DM's him oh let's talk you know maybe
they'll advertise with us we end up
getting an acquisition offer from this
person that's not the deal we ended up
going with but it gave us the leverage
in the deal we did end up going with uh
and like opened this door into
acquisition and it's all like if we
hadn't tweeted out that thing that we
were doing with Mr Beast
I don't think this person would have
followed and then I don't think that
conversation would happen and so the
world Works in these really funny ways
where this like kind of amazing
acquisition we had this year
I don't know they could have just as
easily not happened or been for a lot
less had we not like just done this
totally unrelated thing that's good good
things happen because it's great
all right Andrew what you got best
investment
so Mine mine's actually an investment I
made a couple years ago but it's taken a
while to play out and it's very small
um but I really like this one so
um you guys know Sophia Amoroso I think
she's been on the podcast before
um I met Sophia like five or six years
ago and she just had the experience with
nasty gal and she's like I'm trying to
figure out what to do next I've written
this book called girl boss and I've kind
of built this community around it this
social following I want to turn it into
a business and I said like look you know
I think you should bootstrap this but
she got mobbed with uh VCS and so it was
easy money great valuation raised like
10 million bucks or something and
because she took VC money she had this
really wonderful business but she had to
turn into a billion dollar thing and
this is girl so suddenly this is girl
boss and so she uh you know raised all
this money and she's like I'm gonna
build basically like LinkedIn slash like
a social network for female
entrepreneurs to connect them which we
all know is like the world's biggest
lift it's like oh my most impossible to
start a social network and so she ended
up running out of cash getting exhausted
she sold it to attention capital and
they basically were just like [__] we
don't know what to do about this like we
we shouldn't have bought this and so
they reached out to us
and we were able to buy it for a really
really cheap just because the business
was totally distressed
um and so you know we looked at it and
we're like okay like let's just go back
to basics this business has almost 2
million social followers and email
subscribers and we just did basic stuff
we built a daily email newsletter we
sold ads we did social ads we did
affiliate we rebooted the podcast
brought on a great CEO and it's just
been this phenomenal base hit and I just
got an update from our CEO uh Lulu who's
like freaking amazing and basically now
the business is I won't say numbers but
it's making as much as we paid for it
every year in profit and I think it's
probably 5 or 10x more valuable than
what we paid for it at least
um so I I just love that kind of stuff
where we're able to take a business that
shouldn't have raised venture or you
know kind of failed in Venture Land and
actually make it a sustainable business
that'll be going for five or ten years
at least that's crazy yeah that's really
cool I like those and I think there's
gonna be a bunch of those Venture
businesses that fail that's another one
if you're a venture business and you're
not gonna be able to raise the next
round because the whole Market is turned
or whatever uh it's not over and there's
like a way to structure these deals I
think most Founders just throw in the
towel don't know what to do with that
asset but uh again
there's a lot there's a lot of these
businesses where you let's say a
business gets to five or ten million
dollars of Revenue and they're burning
you know a million two million a month
because they're like Venture backed or
whatever to the founder you know they're
just like okay well this is worth
nothing you know let's go sell to
Facebook and we'll take it Aqua hire and
they actually will throw out their
existing business that business has
value and people like us and enduring
will buy it and turn it around and make
you know make it into something that'll
actually make them proud
um so yeah I mean it's it all is not
like enduring to that with up Council
that's what that was the example totally
can we um we gotta do worship my worst
one is a personal real estate like I
bought real estate over the last two
years and I'm in I'm made money on on
all of it so far and like technically
speaking like it's all like gonna beat
the stock market well that's easy
because the stock market sucks but like
some of my investment it's like my
Airbnb it's still like a eight percent
return or something like that but it's
just a [__] headache dude I regret
buying real estate I wish I didn't own
any real estate and I wish I just
invested in other people's funds
yeah that's my worst investment it just
it's caused me a dispersional amount of
headache yeah that's a good one uh all
right mine is uh mine's really hard to
choose so many losers to choose from
this year so uh so people know my
portfolio is essentially tech stocks and
crypto
um tech stocks down somewhere between 40
and 85 percent this year crypto down 75
percent this year or sometimes 100 in
certain cases uh I think Luna has to be
my pick because it went to zero
um and so that was just like you know
what a 100 loss that happened in like
three days so last year this episode
last year here's here's Sean's company
to watch Tara slash Luna that was his
answer I said company to watch and it
sure did give you some entertainment
yeah you want you watched it go down and
then his prediction was that the Winkle
VI twins the the Winklevoss twins are
gonna be richer than Zuckerberg so
that is a long-term prediction but you
you bet on Luna so so you're gonna
double down this is the question are you
gonna double down on your winkle VI
prediction and what's the timeline and
what's the punishment if you lose no no
these are supposed to be crazy
predictions these are not supposed to be
things I think are going to happen
they're sort of like far-fetched
predictions no I don't I don't want to
double down on that I would say that's
looking way less likely now than it did
then
um but you know it's basically like a
Facebook stock got crushed a little bit
this year too I I had calculated that I
think I forgot what it is now but I
think Bitcoin would have needed to be at
if Bitcoin got to 2 million dollars a
coin then the Winkle and Facebook had
like you know
uh you know kept his value or something
like that
based on how much Bitcoin they owned I
thought okay at that point they all have
surpassed uh a suit but the Hedge was
always if Zucker owns any Bitcoin then
they can really never pass him
um you know if he put a minority stake
in but I don't think Zuck cares if the
wake of fire are rich or not I I don't
think that's a concern of his
so what's what's yours Andrew
um so mine is really just Venture in
general so we I've been doing Angel
Investing For 10 plus years and I think
I've done well
um
on a cash basis I've got a lot of money
back but I haven't actually like if I
think about it
um even if I've made 15 to 30 a year I
haven't had access to that cash the
entire time whereas in my main business
when I buy a business and I make you
know make 20 or 30 return I'm actually
getting that cash and I'm compounding it
and then I'm investing it and doing more
and more and more and I think
psychologically there's a big difference
between owning a whole bunch of
businesses and doing 50 million dollars
in ebitda versus uh owning a bunch of
stakes that are a liquid and a bunch of
venture businesses where maybe you'll
get your money in 10 to 15 years and so
I don't think that it's necessarily
saying I don't want to invest in Venture
go forward but it's just been
I think it's been a bad if I think of it
as if my goal is to maximize my capital
and feel rich it's not the best way to
do that I think that I'm much better off
incubating businesses and uh buying
businesses because it's a very steady 15
to 30 percent cash return and I feel it
I feel the win in a much bigger way and
I think that like anyone over the last
two years there's some businesses where
I look at the valuation I invested at
and I I knew it at the time I sucked it
up and was like [__] you know this is
just the world we're in but there's some
businesses with like now maybe like four
million dollars of Revenue and they
raised it like 100 million dollar
valuation and I'm just like okay that's
just gone yeah well
that sucks
we all just we all just said horrible
things that we did this year I don't
know just just bask in the uh in the in
the hill Look At You Know You're Gonna
you can't you can't have a non-error
right you know like you can't be an
investor and not have a portfolio of bad
Investments of bad decisions right like
that is there's not really a thing if
you're gonna do this uh and you're gonna
take you know the appropriate amount of
risk that would get a reward you can't
have a zero percent error rate and so I
don't think it's anything to be shy of
also you know I think a lot of people
you know are have portfolios that are
down this year just by the nature of
like what's going on in the market
there's that uh there's that logic brain
coming in to save you yeah I know I mean
that but that's like a that's where the
logic brain is actually like useful all
right like I learned this in poker too
like you oh I had pocket aces and I lost
I literally know people that will fold
pocket queens or something like that in
poker why because they're traumatized
from the bad beat they got one time and
there are Jacks I hate Jacks like you
what do you mean you hate pocket Jacks
why
um like why don't you you know just
because you got your money in good but
it turned out not the way you wanted
like you know being able to assess the
decision and not the result is so key
what I when I'm making fun of myself for
for fomoing into Investments it's
because I think my decision was bad sure
the result was bad but my decision was
bad I have many Investments where I
think the decision is good and the
result might be bad for a period of time
that's okay uh but being able to
separate the twos is super important
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
um Sam what topic you want to go to
which category dude I want to combine
book of the year and favorite podcasts
or news person newsletter or person you
subscribe to so I want to like we'll do
a few actionable things like best things
that we um yeah like best bit bits of
content mine for a favorite person I
sort of favorite person is it's two you
already named one of them Paul Graham
dude Paul Graham is such a beautiful
writer I started reading all of his work
again this year he's such an awesome
writer he talks about money living
happiness raising a family he's a really
good writer I love reading him the other
one is cultural tutor do you guys know
who cultural tutor is on Twitter never
heard of it so it's this person
um who I don't think they're crazy
popular but I'm going to give you an
example of a thing that they tweeted so
it's called It's called The the cultural
tutor a beautiful education that's their
thing and so
they'll do like posts about like um uh
I'll I'll let me find a good one but
it's all about culture so basically
right now uh minimalism is a thing so if
you look at like a lot of new buildings
minimalism is a thing and the cultural
tutor will do this thread saying uh this
is actually pretty lame about this
architecture it's pretty boring here's
the ornate stuff that we used to do and
here's why we used to do it and here's
why we do minimalism now and it makes
you like question uh certain things that
we're doing or another one could be
um
um here's like a famous uh piece of art
and it was actually revolutionary uh and
here's or here's why Mona Lisa here's
why it looks like her eyes are following
you and this doesn't seem interesting
now but it was interesting because back
then here's how they used to do things
and here's what was actually
revolutionary about that painting things
like that I love the cultural tutor it's
a really good follow
that's a good one um you said you were
gonna combine that with book of the year
book of the Year Blitz have you ever
read Blitz Andrew it's about the story
of drug use during World War II
I mean you you've got meth and you've
got Hitler I mean what could go wrong
it's a frame breaking book basically the
whole hypothesis was that during World
War II you know how like they gave
soldiers like pieces of chocolate and
cigarettes to keep them happy well and
in Nazi Germany era they gave them meth
and one of the one of the reasons it
says Hitler was being crazy and making a
lot of the decisions that he did not
only was he like a hateful crazy person
but they're saying it was also because
he was on meth the whole time and he was
going nutty and one of the reasons why
he killed himself was he basically ran
out of drugs in the last two weeks in
his bunker what do you got there Sean is
that Blitz right there no this is that
place I'm looking at the book I think
I'm gonna choose but Andrew go go next
so my favorite podcast I'm absolutely
obsessed with Founders which is by David
senra and what he basically does is he
reads business biographies
um and then he summarizes them really
really well so there's a lot of I've
read a lot of business biographies I
really enjoy them but there's a lot of
them where I'm like I just I'm not gonna
spend 15 hours of my life learning about
JFK's dad right there's this there's
there's always books on my bookshelf
that taunt me and so I read that book
He's a patriarchy yeah
I read about a quarter of it it was
great but but um he he'll do like the
one one and a half hour summary and so a
it's a great way to remind yourself like
I I read Titan a couple years ago about
John D Rockefeller and I re-listened to
it it reminded me of a lot of the
lessons and then B it'll actually tell
me do I want to read this book is this
person actually interesting or just give
me a cursory understanding of that
person so I absolutely love that one in
terms of books the one that I loved over
the last year is the operator which is
about David Geffen the guy is a absolute
lunatic it's fascinating like the
picture of him
um you know why is he the way he is deep
dive on him
started he started
records I mean this guy this guy was
like um he's touched so many Industries
you know huge musicians too at this
point like yeah I mean yeah fascinating
career but also an incredible investor
um and capital allocator and stuff but
what a fascinating book and it's one of
those ones where it's very unflattering
but it's incredible
okay that's worth like five or ten
billion dollars at this point I mean
he's like a big deal all right I'll do
um book I'm gonna have I got two two
picks that I thought were good uh I only
read probably three or four books this
year but uh this one
so think on these things by
krishnamurthy that's like a uh life
philosophy book that uh bro I love you
said that was your favorite book one
time and I asked you how far into the
book you've read and you said you're on
the first three pages yeah actually uh
I'm only about 30 pages in now uh so
I've gone from three to Thirty in a year
I think it might have been my pick last
year too
um this book is so heavy man it's got
like uh let me see how far dude it's not
okay it's like 250 Pages 110 pages in
um so some 110 pages in and uh it's it's
an amazing book the second one is uh
Andrew you probably read this richer
wiser happier
it's a great book for anybody who likes
investing
um and basically yeah there's a great
book for anybody who likes investing I
think it's a it's a
it's a fun read so uh those are my two
favorite books that I read this year and
then podcast newsletter or person I'm
gonna give two kind of shout outs
a person one that's a little under the
radar is called 10K diver if you follow
this guy on Twitter
so yeah the 10K diver the bio just it's
the literally it's a number 10 then K
diver uh it says I help people
understand the fundamentals of finance
and investing and um I think it's called
10K diver because it's like the form 10K
like the the
that's like the the name of the form or
whatever so uh he just gives really
great threads about like very basic
fundamentals of Finance and I find
myself reading these and thinking oh
surely I know you know about whatever
topic it is certainly I know about stock
based compensation certainly I know you
know whatever cash flow and then you
read it and you're like I always learn
something from it and I think he's a
great writer he's very clear he's very
helpful
um I just think it's a great great one
to follow it's like you know there's a
lot of junk food on Twitter and I would
say that 10K diver is not junk food I
even took his like Maven course
um
but did you really I I only attended
like half of the sessions just because
like you know it's hard to make that
much time
um super interesting dude and uh and you
know I I don't know the course wasn't
like mind breaking for me but
um
I don't know it's it's all good stuff
it's all good stuff and so I really I
really liked uh I really like the way
this guy thinks
um okay so that's the the person one and
okay book so I did book all right we're
good we're good on those we all all
three did ours
yeah all right cool yeah what uh what
topic you want to do next
wild predictions
okay what you got
mine's easy I think by the way you want
me to read your wild predictions from
last year should I read our predictions
yeah all right our predictions from last
year Sams was
um
San Francisco is going to be cool again
San Francisco will be cool again you
think you hit that or no
no but I don't think I'm I I I'm I early
I'm not off my prediction but I'm but
yeah I'm a little early it's gonna come
back man because Sanford I went back
there it is awesome San Francisco is
awesome yeah you said something about
the YouTuber meet Kevin and that uh
he will be like and his company's gonna
break out or something like that I don't
know what that prediction was oh yeah I
totally was wrong uh totally at home
Diagnostics you said was the industry to
watch
yeah nothing happened there and then you
said overrated the Creator economy slash
web3 nailed it yeah I emailed that one
um Andrew your predictions were that
high and high salary inflation is not
here to stay companies are going to
Outsource an offshore
um Talent
what do you think about that one
I still think it's right I think that it
just took I think we're just seeing it
now basically as these Tech layoffs
happen I think they're going to go
globally right um and then you said
overrated you said nfts
um I think we I think we structured this
differently last time we did like
companies to watch overrated thing to
watch I said overrated with spax I think
that was right
um I said a company to watch Tara Luna
that was way wrong and my crazy
prediction was that the book of I will
end up richer than Zuck which is you
know early like we already talked about
okay so this year what do you got for a
prediction or predictions for 2023
so we structured it differently but let
me say my mine too because they're fast
one Elon Musk either dies or he or he
gets canceled or he gets canceled in an
incredibly like serious way and Tesla
stock completely tanks the second thing
is so open eye open AI
um something involving regulations gonna
happen because like there's already been
little bits of pieces like if you Google
or if you use open Ai and you ask them
about coal they say like you know we
think that
climate change is wrong yada yada or if
you ask them about uh race
um they say something like you know race
is a social and cultural construct and
you we don't we don't want to give it
our opinion on this like they kind of
like but they actually do insert their
opinion
um and I think that there's gonna be
some weird [__] going on where like
right now like like for example they'll
like say like hey we'll give you a
hundred thousand dollars for 10 of your
company if you build on top of our
platform and there should be all these
new tools but it's all going to be
underlined with this like potential
massive bias that open AI has and I
think there's got to be some type of
Regulation around it do you know what I
mean yeah Andrew what you got
predictions
and by the way these are supposed to be
when we said we said wild predictions so
we're again we're not saying we're sure
these are going to happen these are like
sort of interesting predictions
yes you remember like five years ago
everyone was saying Apple doesn't
innovate anymore they can't do Ai and
what was happening is that Google at
least historically has innovated in
public so they're constantly constantly
releasing new features and showing off
these kind of half-baked ideas that are
in their r d Labs whereas Apple has
always been very opaque they'll work on
something for seven years they won't
share it and then all of a sudden
they'll release it and I think that same
thing is happening with gpt3 and AI I do
believe that while right now I can say
I'm using gpt3 instead of Google I think
Google has probably been working on
something similar for years and years
and years and is probably very far ahead
maybe not ahead of gpt3 necessarily but
that they have their own offering and so
I just think it's a those there's going
to be a lot of a lot of other players in
that space coming out over the next
probably three to six months and that it
will be there's going to be an ecosystem
of offerings similar to AWS and Azure
and Google Cloud I think it'll be the
same thing with gpt3 Google maybe
Microsoft I don't know who else
cool
um Sam I agree with your Elon one that's
one of my predictions I think he gets
canceled in a big way or one of his
companies goes broke I think that is a a
good wild prediction
um but I'm actually not going to predict
I think that yeah he he's gonna get me
too'd I think yeah I feel like he
already has and somehow in me already I
mean he already did I mean yeah kind of
I think he's uncancelable kind of given
all this stuff I think people think that
and then it's gonna get the number of
things still gonna happen I think he's
gonna They're Gonna Cancel the
uncancelable
um but I'm not really going to predict
anything that's like
the macro because a who the hell knows
and B who the hell cares I'm actually
going to take a page out of out of the
book of uh of something we respect
highly here on MFM
call on your own shot so my predictions
are about myself so here's my here's my
predictions about myself uh I predict
that this is the year
that I get ripped uh I predict that I
turned the corner and and not like oh I
get back in shape no your boy's never
been in this kind of shape so I'm gonna
get ripped for the first time and uh I
also believe that I'm gonna start a
company that is
um special I don't I don't want to put a
dollar amount because these special
things take time so it's not going to
happen in one year but I'm gonna do I'm
gonna start the thing
that will be my kind of like
um
the thing I'm known for for a very long
time the Legacy thing or the thing that
you know builds the the big the big
wealth the big Empire I think it's gonna
happen this year so those are my
predictions uh for myself for 2023 well
I'm happy you called your shot I
actually agree with you I think you're
gonna do that too I think you're you're
more than likely gonna create that
company than you are get ripped but uh
you're just giving me that fuel thank
you for the fuel
are you willing to take drugs to get
ripped no I'm all natural you're
unwilling to take drugs I like the liver
King
uh okay well then yeah then I think that
you're well dude getting ripped is hard
man I'm I'm pretty ripped right now and
everyone keeps asking me what I did and
you know what I did I just didn't eat
and it's really really a pain in the
butt I don't really like doing it and so
I don't know like I don't think you need
to be that ripped what's your definition
of ripped I guess visible abs
yeah you got to get to what is it 12
body fat 12 it's not you can be you can
live a good life and be at 12 but below
10 where I am trying to get it it sucks
I'm just hungry and cold yeah I'm not
gonna do that but it'll be visible all
right um
let's do another one uh coolest moment
of the year for you what was the coolest
moment of the year uh
personally that you had
dude mine is like it kind of felt like
we crossed a Chasm for like kind of like
this podcast being well known and like
that's a little I didn't want to do a
selfish one honestly I almost feel free
yeah
I almost I wanted to say you selling the
milk Road I actually did think that was
cool
um uh the the seeing you do that I got a
lot of joy out of and a lot of like even
though I wasn't involved it was like I
felt a sense of pride of like we came
together the advisor so you know you
were involved
yeah so feel free to send me some money
but uh uh no I think like us getting
popular this year like it really felt
like this is the first time it happened
I agree uh it's something has changed
Andrew what about you coolest moment of
the year for you
so I've talked about this before but I
feel like what I actually if I really am
honest what I like about business aside
from making money and not making my life
easier is meeting interesting people and
uh you know I got to know uh Andrew
huberman this year and we ended up
partnering so basically like I've got a
foundation I've been giving a bunch of
money away to science and so I met
huberman maybe is that who you wrote the
channel or two ago you wrote the check
to science
yeah yeah exactly just science but um I
met huberman like a year or two ago and
basically we did this thing where when
people subscribed to his premium podcast
a bunch of the money goes to
um basically funding science and
research that he wants to fund and I
basically said look I'll double I'll
double every single dollar that you
donate and so we've got this partnership
and I just love that kind of stuff where
would you I can work with some people I
respect benefactor do something that I
think is good so that's a cool moment
you've become a benefactor
you get to use one of these words that's
like from the 1800s when you do things
like that
yeah it feels good it's fun dude and
plus you have an excuse now to hang out
with the dreamiest guy on Earth Andrew
huberman yeah totally say I'm jealous
anytime you want
um for sure all right my coolest moment
of the year was
you were there for this Sam when we were
at Camp MFM and we got to go do a tour
of uh of Duke's uh basketball stadium
and we're in there and then we uh we're
sitting down gave they gave us the talk
it was an art it was a good experience
at that point but we had a there's a
moment that made it a good experience to
like a keystone memory which was when I
bet Mr Beast ten thousand dollars that I
could hit a shot from half court
and I hit it and the whole thing on
number on number five or something yeah
like the third third attempt hit I was
like I'll again hit this before you the
third attempt I hit it it's on camera it
was it was an amazing fun moment it made
that that trip a little bit more more
special and memorable did he ever pay
you this is where it comes this is where
it gets interesting it's also actually
my biggest L of the year because he
didn't pay me and then
I had to follow up
and I followed up two times three times
and now I'm basically begging for the
money by the third time you go from like
first time you kind of crack it you're
busting balls a little bit like hey
[__] baby and then the second time
you're like hey man uh didn't pay by the
time it's the third one now this awesome
dope moment has turned into an L because
now I'm having to go yeah I think I
think I think you need to take him to
small claims exactly that's how I'm
doing that via iMessage and I was like
we have it on video we have the bed up
dude we have the bet on video no I know
and so this this baller moment of
confidence of being like hey betcha 10
grand I can hit the shot and then
actually hitting it uh with you know
everybody there in the center of you
know cameras Cameron Stadium Cameron
Indoor Stadium
turned into a bit of a small boy moment
of being like hey hey um hey did you
have a chance to hey just I know you're
busy just uh
do you think you can I'll send the
details again maybe maybe it's on my end
dude is he lying about every other uh
donation he's ever no coffeezilla get on
it are there thousands of victims like
me
that's crazy I can't believe you didn't
pay you he doesn't seem like someone who
would he blamed his assistant he's like
oh [__] sorry my assistant I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna have to yell at him
yeah right okay let's do um let's do the
craziest most delusional person of the
year that we met this one's for for us
it's probably easy it's Billy McFarland
did you hear that oh did you hear that
interview Sean or uh Andrew no I did I
didn't hear it I don't like when you
guys interview people like that because
I I know I know it's like interesting
and stuff but I feel like if you if only
even if only five percent of people hear
that and go hey he actually sounds like
a good guy I just think like he's gonna
go and [__] more people over I don't
know what do you guys think I I didn't
and uh
we do those bad things he goes and
listens to all in instead he doesn't
listen to the episode he goes on strike
Sean Hall hardly disagrees with you I
think yeah I totally disagree I think uh
you know this podcast is our vehicle to
have conversations with interesting
people and everybody's an adult they
should judge for themselves whether they
think this person's full of [__] or
deserves a second chance or whatever on
the Pod itself he told us what he was
doing and literally with a one pause I
just go that's a horrible idea and I
actually felt bad that I was that brutal
about it uh but it really was I thought
a horrible idea and I felt the need to
just like say it so
um I think it's one thing if you invite
them on and they just like like I see
this sometimes people just like suck up
to people and the other is to be like
dude what the hell were you thinking or
they're like oh you know I just thought
this like are you serious like really
you like are you gonna look at me with a
straight face and say that this was all
just an honest mistake like you had to
have known right so I think as long as
you are real with your questions uh then
it's all good but that's my you know
it's my opinion I just think I just
think it's like um it's giving air time
to people that are bad right like I
would say Billy McFarland is probably a
psychopath right but the Bernie mate
obviously documentary on Netflix coming
out in three days are you gonna watch
that Bernie Madoff is dead
if I if you had if you had Bernie Madoff
on your podcast and you were like hey so
like what happened tell us your story
and even if you kind of call him out if
he's like a belief like a real
psychopath is like pretty charming and
like believable and you listen to them
and there's going to be a percentage of
people that hear that and the difference
with Madoff is he's in jail right the
then like Billy McFarland again I have
no idea you know he he served his time
sure but like he's probably gonna go on
and do more sketchy [__] or I don't know
any of these people who have a pattern
of behavior of doing Psychopathic
fraudulent stuff I just don't think they
should get any air time frankly yeah
okay fair enough I think there's a lot
of people who would agree with you uh I
don't personally but most most probably
do but I actually I'm partially on
Sean's side I am mostly on Sean's side
but I I do feel guilt sometimes like
there's another person who Sean wants to
have on that I think there's not a
chance we should uh but uh
so imagine here's here's how I would
tell you to think about this like
imagine that you so you know Sam you've
told me stories of guys who I remember
you told me there was some average
Advertiser who is [__] you over and
not paying you and you felt very cheated
and Sean I mean that guy that you sued
who you felt like was chiseling you the
landlord or whatever now let's say I
have a podcast and I say well there's
two sides to every story and he's
fascinating I'm gonna go have that guy
on my podcast as the victim you'd be
like what the [__]
that question I would say ask that
question as long as you actually ask the
questions and you uh you're not just
giving them like a chance to lie or say
BS in a way that's like it's obviously
BS but you let them skate on it um like
that's what happened with like Sam
bakeries yeah but look at look at Tai
Lopez look at Tai Lopez Tai Lopez got
legitimized by being on MFM a lot of
people heard him and went you know what
he's not a bad guy and you know Sam kind
of likes him and whatever and like what
has he been doing over the last wait
wait wait what did I do I didn't do
anything you said you're you were like
yeah I met him I met him in a hotel and
he was actually a really nice guy right
and it's like of course he is he's just
is charming I like everyone
I like to respect the audience and
meaning I believe that it you should
have the opportunity to hear it and make
your own decision I don't pretend that
I'm your parent and I'm legitimizing
them or I'm telling you they're good or
bad or whatever I'm just letting you see
them and if you see them and you decide
that they're great great if you decide
that we didn't ask tough questions and
you can't make a decision but Andrew you
promote uh you promote Bill Ackman
sure like I absolutely do he's my
business person and I'm not saying I
actually don't know all the details how
could you put them in the same category
well a lot of I'm not saying I do but a
lot of people do don't they Andrew like
that's objective you can actually you
can at least say that like a lot of
people do think that he's uh what did
Bill actually do that's on on considered
controversy oh yeah what did he do
exactly that would be like fraudulent or
something like that
always made some Investments that have
turned out badly but he's never I don't
think he's predatory in any way I think
Bill is a great individualism I've seen
the person you know legitimate is when
he went on what's the MLM and he was
like I uh the whole markets he basically
was like hell is coming blah blah but
didn't disclose it he had basically a
giant short position yeah maybe caused a
panic maybe didn't no but he he had
already if he actually look he wrote a
letter about this he'd already sold
almost his entire position he had like
one or two percent left and I spoke to
Bill two weeks before that and he was
freaking the [__] out like similar
benefit greatly if people started
selling right he had a giant no sure no
he actually made a bunch of money he
wasn't
no no no no that I think it's a big
misunderstanding if you actually look at
the Timeline he'd already sold out of
that position
what about uh Herbalife
Herbalife I mean Herbalife he went out
and he said this is a multi-level
marketing scheme and what ended up
happening is the FTC investigated it and
they gave them a 200 million dollar fine
and they got up to the point of saying
hey is this an ml they settled with them
for like 200 million it was the largest
uh FTC fine ever and Herbalife the FTC
commissioner was asked is Herbalife a
multi-level marketing pyramid scheme and
she said it's not not one right because
she was legally Bound by not calling it
that so basically bill was right and
that was an instance where he lost a
shitload of money
trying to fight a bad guy did that
really happen
by the way I'm not saying Bill Ackman
sucks I think I'm I'm I like Bill but
you're not I know
no that's not that's not what I'm
applying I'm I'm saying that some people
maybe think that he's full of it right I
I think yes absolutely there's people
that are critical I think there's a
great quote on this I'm not saying he is
the tallest the tallest blade of grass
is the first to get cut and I think Bill
is very loud and he is always confident
and he's usually right but not always
and so someone like that I think when
they're not right everyone loves to [__]
all over them yeah yeah I'm not saying
that I don't think he's in the category
where he's got like you know
there I don't know of any accusations
about stuff like that I think some
people are just like he's not as good he
loses money he's not as good if an
investor as he says or his his Fame
would lead you to believe that's a
criticism but that's like any that's
like that's like criticizing someone's
Skittle LeBron James is not as good as
Michael Jordan or whatever right like
that's different than saying somebody is
you know I think it's like it's like
fixating on Warren Buffett buying
Dexter's shoe and it not working out and
then saying or you know Warren Buffett
did some deals in his early career where
he bought a business and he ended up
having to lay a lot of people off right
now you could build a narrative that
well Warren but everyone says Warren
Buffett's so great but what about this
and what about this but if you look at
it and there's a hundred Investments and
10 of them didn't go well you know you
can fixate on the 10 but you can look at
the long-term performance bills
compounded at 20 plus percent I think 25
or something crazy uh maybe not quite
that but something exceptional so again
like he's my business partner obviously
I'll defend him I'm not by the way yeah
I don't think he's anywhere are near
those guys I'm not saying I'm not saying
I think he sucks I actually like him a
lot from what I read about him I'm just
saying my point being is a lot of people
a lot of awesome people have haters and
just because you have a lot of haters
doesn't necessarily mean I don't think
you should we shouldn't have you on
that's my whole point but imagine okay
you guys have a newspaper right
effectively you guys own the New York
Times of tech startup Bros right like
that that's what that's what MFM is you
guys have this huge audio quote you on
that would it be ethical for the editor
editor of the New York Times to put an
op-ed from Bernie Madoff on the front
cover right it was not an op-ed it's an
interview it's a big big difference
again I hear I totally I totally agree I
hear you guys I know you want to like
stir the pot and it's good good
listening I just for me like I just hate
when these weasels get okay let's get
back yeah let's move on all right Andrew
who's the most delusional person you've
met this year
so okay so it's a delusional person who
I think is amazing
um you guys probably will say the same
person it's Brian Johnson uh I met Brian
almost a year ago and I remember sitting
down with him and looking just looking
at him he's like a translucent glowing
Twilight vampire like he just looks if
you cut his arm off there's circuits
under there I and he's so incredibly
well spoken and like like you I Sam I
think you said he's like the the Elon
but like behind the scenes and quiet
right it's special I think he's amazing
uh I think he's like
he's like dedicating his life to
basically being a test uh you know a
test case for the rest of us so I really
admire him uh and I think he's really
how do you look in person did he look uh
on our pot he almost looked he almost
looked a little ill like he was so
skinny yeah he was so pale that there
was no pigment in his skin like
literally like literally looked like
um what's that movie uh with the [__]
what is it uh the robot guy alien alien
with the robot guy like just totally
pale humanoid that's uh that's my pick
too uh Brian Johnson for the for the
exact same reason so we'll we'll move to
the next one uh he was he was you're
right crazy and delusional in the best
way possible
um yeah as a mean that as a compliment
um
okay did you guys have another category
that you really like your answer for
does anybody like think they got
something good because we can just go to
those the the relationship hacks and the
um
what you got so
um they always say like the best first
date is an adrenaline kind of event
right so like you want to go on a hike
you want to get your heart pounding
maybe you go and do like a ropes you
know those uh what are they called
they're like rope swings through the
forest whatever like something that gets
your heart pounding because when someone
Associates you with a peak experience
like a physical feeling of peak
experience that's very positive and it
bonds you and the same thing is true
with alcohol so I I kind of stopped
drinking
um maybe like seven or eight years ago
and I've kind of mourned the ability to
go and you know down a pint with someone
because they always end up telling you
everything they tell you about their
business and the problems they're having
and you know what's going on with their
wife it's like hang out once drunk is
like hanging out 10 times times sober
and so what I've been doing is I've been
been inviting people that I would
otherwise have like a meeting with over
to my house and we'll do a really long
sauna and a cold plunge and I've been
finding like I just feel so incredibly
bonded to people because I'm having like
my body is pumped full of all these
endogenous drugs uh and it's been really
good it's been kind of like drinking
with someone dude can I tell you what
mine was here's I'm gonna read let me
word re read it word for word invite
people have them come over for dinner
and cook for them and we take ice baths
together
after dinner before dinner what are you
doing
before do you tell them some trucks or
how do you prepare are you just spray it
on them or or sometimes sometimes
they're just spraying on them and I have
a towel already and I have shorts and
it's so funny that that's exactly what
mine is another relationship hack that I
have is I bring my wife to almost
everything so so it feels like a family
a gathering and also she's like like hot
and like well like well read and like
can have a discussion so it
automatically makes me seem better
you're the guy with the hot book smart
wife oh yeah
I bet uh uh yeah so Adrian I had the
same thing another thing that I that I
typically don't do and I and I think
this is the worst way to hang out is
while exercising I hate when people say
let's go get a workout together I'm like
I don't want to I never want to do that
ever I will never do a workout and hang
out
yeah I want silence same I'm the
opposite I love love a workout together
that's a great it's a great idea I've
had multiple listeners from the Pod be
like hey I'm in town uh winter workout
like I'll just come swing by and we'll
just do it together and I was like oh
that's perfect I don't want to
separately beat you and uh I'll learn so
much about you just seeing how you work
out that this is uh like how you deal
with like you know adversity like you
know how you're how are you as a hang
you know do you work out like all these
things it's a great tell all right I got
two little hacks the first is a
principle that I've had for a long time
it's called don't attend the party host
the party this is my um I have a rule I
don't attend other people's events
typically unless it's a real good friend
who really wants me to but I will host
so um I think hosting is it is let's say
five times the work but I think it's 500
times the payoff uh when you actually
host the the event so we uh Camp MFM is
a perfect example of this uh and when
you host it
um the other the other hack in this is
make it epic because it's going to be
more fun for you to it's like all the
logistical work is kind of the same
but if you just use your creativity to
make it a more interesting people will
come and they'll have like a whole
memory to you know a whole experience uh
with you so with Camp MFM the way we did
it where we flew to this place we had
the basketball trainer Mr Beast and
Hassan were there like interesting
people were there we all stayed in you
know an Airbnb a giant house together
like that was a instead of just doing a
networking event we made it fun and we
made it different and I think I know you
get a bunch of benefits of being the one
who hosted it that's the first one the
second one I would say the actual
relationship hack with with my wife is
so I'm a pretty chill dude but I do I do
have one Achilles heel which is I'm very
very very impatient and what that means
is like you know my wife is like slow to
leave the house trying to go somewhere
it's like oh dude why does this take so
I feel like I've wasted half my life
waiting to leave the house
um you know just with kids it gets like
really slow so I've always had this
impatience thing and I've tried to be
like all right I'm gonna be more patient
I'm gonna be more patient and I realized
that that was actually a Fool's errand
that the way to be more patient
for me is to get in a fight in the
morning and what I started doing was I
hired this MMA trainer and I would wake
up early I do my workout in the morning
and I would Spar and what I found is
that if I Spar in the morning
I've gotten a really hard strenuous like
endorphin kick you know done the rest of
the day I'm just sort of like
yo it's whatever like I I can wait yeah
you can take take an extra 10 minutes uh
you want to change your shirt because
maybe this one's a little maybe a little
too hot it's like go ahead go change
your shirt yeah no problem I'll be here
at the front door chilling and I have
become such a more patient person just
by doing a sparring session in the
morning it's a pretty extreme step to
take but it is so far the only thing
that has gotten me to change this like
really terrible personality trait after
so long
nothing like getting punched in the face
I was I I think I told you that you did
tell me that and the other experience I
had like this was I've been skydiving
once in the morning and the rest of the
day you could stress me out if you tried
I was in I was a completely immune to
stress and so I think there's something
to this like having a very exhilarating
or adrenaline kick in the morning it
just makes the rest of the day
completely non-stressful that doesn't
mean you don't do anything it just means
you don't stress
we were talking about the cold plunges
and um I was just listening to a
huberman lab and he was talking about
this exact thing so when you're in cold
it obviously stresses your body you get
a huge dopamine Spike and you get
adrenaline norepinephrine all that kind
of stuff and he was saying that if you
do stressful things while you're in the
cold plunge it adapts you to dealing
with stress better so you should
definitely get a cold plunge and then
argue with your wife while you're in it
or something
sounds smart
uh so that's best religion pack what's
the what was the other one you said uh
oh favorite tool or product under what
it's favorite uh tool or product under a
thousand dollars what you guys got
so I always have this problem
um I'll travel to a city and I'll try
and think of you know I'll be like okay
I'm going to New York on this day who do
I know in New York and it'll be
whoever's top of Mind whoever I've just
been texting with or something and I'll
go and I'll have a couple meetings and
then I'll leave and then I'll remember
you know it's like when you leave the
grocery store and you realize there's
like three or four important things you
forgot I always realize oh [__] I forgot
to meet all these people I really wanted
to see and so um I've tried a couple
different tools for this but I found one
I really liked it's this one called clay
it's a personal CRM which we all hate I
know it's like a horrible business but
um they do a really good job of
basically tapping into your Twitter your
LinkedIn your iMessage all the pla your
email all the places where you contact
me and this is uh Earth
clay.earth yeah and so basically it's a
huge database of all the people you know
and so what I do now is I go in clay and
I'll just be like I'll type in New York
and it'll show me everyone in New York
and then I don't miss people uh and
that's been huge this is a beautiful
website
yeah I turn right away because it helps
us like uh same problem with all crms
for me where
like you get out what you put in and I'm
just not willing to put it put it enough
but there's no I don't use it like I
don't you I don't update it it's just
when I go traveling it's just a database
of people I know and where they live can
I uh mine is my body tutor and I don't
know if Sean that if that's yours as
well but have you heard about my body
tutor Andrew
no very simple all right here's what it
is I spent 600 a month and every day my
coach her name's Heather calls me and
says
what are you gonna eat today and I tell
her and she's those yesterday according
to your MyFitnessPal you ate this this
and this this thing was bad how'd that
make you feel and I say I feel horrible
I'm not going to do it again today and
she just shames me
or educates me on why I made a good or
bad decision and we like work backwards
from whichever goal I want it's it's a
five minute phone call uh that's been
the bit the best tool I've ever used
that's a good one that's all it is I um
so I'm a pretty disorganized guy so my
favorite tools or products have been the
one that helped me get organized and I
got two that kind of save my ass this
year
um
I don't know Sam did you when you were
at the hustle did you ever have like a
bookkeeper
yes
and do you remember life before a
bookkeeper and a life after bookkeeper
before it's stressful and like now I
know that like I didn't know what the
difference between revenue and cash flow
was and I didn't like understand like
that like you take expenses and you like
I'm amortize them I didn't understand
all that stuff so it was as if I was
driving at night time without headlights
on
the perfect way to describe it that's
how I've been my whole life and I would
always wonder
man how do these other people have their
[__] together how is it you know tax
season comes around I'm just like
scrambling and it's like the worst
version of cramming for a test and so
this year I basically
totally revamp my financial like hygiene
game with a bookkeeper and a tax person
that I love and I'm gonna shout them
both out because they're amazing uh they
were they were so amazing I did invest
in both of the companies because I was
like I have to like you know I I believe
in this uh you know because they saved
my ass so one is called Kick so I think
it's kick.co is the URL and it's
basically if you go to the website I
like their tagline it says self-driving
bookkeeping so basically what they do is
they just say connect your bank your
credit cards and it's like everything
it's like your Amazon you just click
connect connect connect
boom it's all your books and then they
have bookkeeper and she calls me and
she's like here's how you're doing like
here's how you're pacing here's what you
know here's some things you should be
thinking about here's how we can save
you money
um you know blah blah blah and not like
not like spend less but more like tax
wise like here's some things that you
could do and so bookkeeping was the
first one uh and then how much is this
all my books are together it's super
cheap it's like I don't know it's like
99 or 100 199 a month or something like
that it's like if anybody if you're a
Creator like the one big thing is they
they do this for like kind of like small
small businesses like sort of like LLC
types s Corps or um creators so like if
you're a YouTuber or twitch Creator or a
podcaster uh most of them have don't
treat their creator business like a
business and you totally should it is a
business and I think also the law has
now changed so starting next year I
think they have to do like the quarterly
estimated taxes and things like that
like dude 99 of the creators have no
idea what this stuff is or how to do it
and so
um so I love this thing this has been
like kind of a game changer for me out
of having my my p l my cash flow my
balance sheet all of it just like very
clean and then then that gets handed to
the other service gelt and so but guilt
does is kind of amazing I don't know how
much of this I'm supposed to say are
allowed to say it I don't even think
they want me shouting it out because
it's like dude I just signed it I just
signed up
I just signed up with gel uh are you on
the waitlist are you you actually
started using it
I dm'd him and I have a call set up so
the guy tal is this incredible guy he's
an entrepreneur so but for the best
thing so I've I've met many I've had
many like kind of accountants and Tech
strategy people
and I literally walked in and I felt
like I was walking into a meeting like
you know with CIA or something like that
with IRS it's like and and Nick Hoover
said this right he goes yeah dude 95 of
accountants and tax strategy people
they're like they act like government
agents and he's like you can't even he's
like you're just asking questions like
how should I structure this differently
in order to and they can't answer it's
like
they're not creative first of all so
they're not even giving you ideas it's
like if you have the idea they can say
yes or no but it's like dude where am I
supposed to come up with all these ideas
from uh so like they don't give you
ideas first of all and secondly they're
like well did you spend more than 22
hours doing this it's like dude I don't
know I wasn't keeping track of that but
like if I say yes what happens if I say
no what happens I need to understand
like could you just
disarm this it's not even like help me
cheat it's like literally just don't
make this stressful it's been my big
problem with this and so guilt is kind
of amazing because towels he's a Founder
he's an entrepreneur he sold his last
company and he's like dude I just like
he's like personally I just hated taxes
and so I decided to create like the tax
firm I wish existed
and they're amazing so the same thing
they take your books and then what they
do is they're more like yo have you
thought about structuring your
corporations in this way because then
you can get the advantage of qsbs while
still maintaining this advantage and
like they they do everything clean they
do everything by the book but they are
they feel more like your friend helping
you do this than the other way and so
these guys probably save me
I don't know I don't know how much to
save me but I wouldn't be surprised if
it was seven figures of what I've saved
using this thing
um and it's the first time I've been not
stressed on the subject of finding like
bookkeeping and taxes and so like that
has been like a very nice feeling for me
to have versus like this scramble and
always feeling like there was some adult
class that I missed I slept through and
now here's the test like that's how
that's how taxes always felt for me was
I slept through the class and everybody
else took it everybody else is prepared
and I don't know what the [__] I'm doing
and now finally I feel like okay I I
have my notes to take this test dude I
think it's one of the one of those
things that's shocking how many business
people just don't know how to read a
balance sheet and a p l and cash flow
statement and it's if you want to learn
Khan Academy has an amazing introductory
course takes about an hour and you'll
learn everything you need to do you guys
hear this the IRS hired like some like
some absurd number of new Auditors was
it like 18 000 if you're like 80 000 or
or more I don't know like IRS hiring new
agents I think they hired 80 000
um 87 000 new hires and so I think
there's gonna be a [__] little audit
which is why I wanted to be like super
buttoned up with everything
um just because oh man that's another
time suck if you get audited of like
dealing with all that crap so uh you
know I don't think they hire these
people to do nothing it's 80 billion 80
billion in new funding and 87 000 tax
agents isn't that insane that's [__]
crazy
they're gonna have a lot of work to cut
out for them um I think we should almost
wrap up we have we want to do one one or
two yeah let's do one or two more what
are your favorite ones yeah let's do
let's do one what's a really good one
what about biggest change adjustment
you're making yeah I have one go Sam
so
um
for I have a new thing that I'll launch
that it's live but I'll announce it
later
um I'm hiring a CEO for it I've already
like done that and I've never done that
early on I also am doing close to like
I'm being less of a dictator and I'm
also being less metrics driven this
sounds like the freaking douchiest thing
ever but I'll say it but more like Vibe
and energy driven uh basically with the
hustle and like my last company I was
like by the book where it was like all
right I want to see projections we're
going to nail it we're gonna like the
metrics say this therefore like I can
see you putting a metric on the vibe too
like we're in 87 on five this week guys
well like on my last like for all my
companies I'm like look you've got to do
this many outbound calls like we're
gonna like whatever the a b metric is
this is what it is uh like we're going
with a that A1 and I just filed the data
and I was like I don't care and then it
was very much a dictatorship where I
said my rule or my way or the highway
and I'm trying to be a little bit calmer
for my next thing and I think I'll make
way more money that way that's a great
one great adjustment uh Andrew what you
got biggest change or adjustment you're
making in your business life 2023
so last year I don't know if I said this
but my big goal was conquering email
like I just I was overwhelmed by it it
was stressing me out and so now I've
built a system I've fully delegated it
I've got someone dedicated to managing
my email and so I really only get 10 or
15 emails that I have to respond to and
everything else is triaged and responded
to and dealt with so I've conquered
email the problem is now I get a lot of
iMessages like texts and stuff and I'm
going I don't know how to conquer that
other than changing my number which
seems [__] up
um I'm trying to figure that out if
anyone has any ideas please tweet at me
because
um there's it seems like there's no way
if someone has your number they're going
to get to you and I have a really hard
time not responding to text I feel kind
of guilty
um so I'd love to hear you're just
getting like cold texts from strangers
is that the problem dude I get so many
of those not that it's just there's I
mean I get cold text for sure but it's
more just like there's so many people
I've given my number out to and if
someone doesn't get an email response to
me sometimes they'll try and go there I
think like some people have found my
number online like it's just it's just
becoming too much and I'll be like with
email you can kind of turn it off I'll
be putting my kids down for bed and like
reading a Kindle book on my phone and
I'll be getting hit up with text and
it's just the ability to break into your
Consciousness would you just get a new
number sucks
yeah I was thinking about it but I've
had my number since I was like 15. it
feels messed up to do I know but I've
thought about doing that as well
Sam uh okay so you did yours Andrew you
did yours my biggest adjustment
um
you knowing when to use my impulsiveness
so I am an extremely impulsive person
um and that works in like eight out of
ten situations
one of the situations it doesn't work in
is I'm very impulsive with picking
businesses to start
and yeah I will just like start a
business like instantaneously and I will
go and I'll start making it happen
and it's really fun and that wave and
that Thrill is so addictive
and then
11 months later I'm like okay now I have
this business
um was this the business that I wanted
to have was because like I can't do that
many of these at the same time
uh so is this the right are you happy
you started your Ecom thing
um no if I could go back and just pick a
different project I would
um same thing with the milk Road part of
the reason I sold it was I was like I
don't think this was the project that I
want to work on every year
um you know for the next three years and
so if I don't want to work on it for the
next three years I should just sell it
now and like you know uh if I have a
good offer like take it
um but that's kind of a shitty feeling
like there's a celebration in selling
but there's also a bit of a failure it's
like
I've been saying this for a while I want
to work on a project that I don't want
to sell like this podcast time has flown
by where this is the third year we're
doing the Millie awards that means this
Friday is at least three years old
um
I can keep going I would do this for
free I was doing this for free I was
going to do this at a loss so this is
the right type of project for me to do
it's one that I would literally do if
there was no money involved I don't
count the days or the hours I'm not
stressed about the metrics I know it's
going to keep going up because we'll
just keep trying to do a better and
better job I have fun doing it and it's
not a not a drag on my lifestyle right
like perfect project
this has been the only project I've
selected correctly on I would argue
every single business I've started since
the age of 21 was the wrong pick and it
was always just the impulsive pick it
was someone should do this dude I bet I
could do that dude I would just do this
as this all right let me just do it and
I would just do it and then you know
sure enough I'm look looking for the
exit later because it wasn't really the
right project so I'm trying to find the
big changes I'm going to find the
project that's in my zone of Genius
um that is the perfect project for me
it's what I enjoy doing
um and I'm not building it for some
future payoff I'm building it I'm doing
it because I like doing it that it is
the the project that's you know I'm most
interested in and if that changes later
okay that's fine I'm not saying I have
to do it till I'm 99 years old but um
I'm not doing it just kind of like on a
whim so I'm going to be patient and
select the project properly that's good
it's about time I've been telling you
that for 10 years
the best lessons are the ones that you
have to relearn 10 10 times over okay so
the other one was best business idea
yeah do you guys dude
yeah let's end up tell me why your
washer and your dryer are two different
machines
remember to put my wet clothes into the
dryer it's ridiculous this needs to be
one that's honestly that is one of the
smartest actually a really good point
it's it's crazy to me it's crazy to me
that it's two different things that that
actually exists
no it's in it's in Best Buy Home Depot
they're not that great it's a thing
they're not that great yet like I use
them in Europe and they're only okay but
they need to be the norm this needs to
be the norm yeah yeah if you're working
on AI or crypto or self-driving cars
quit and figure this one out like we
gotta put we gotta have our priorities
in order you know how many people are
wasting time
dude like it's like look at James Dyson
look at James Dyson he's worth 18
billion dollars and he just was like
vacuums are terrible I'm gonna rethink
those I mean he could have been working
on AI but no you chose something prior
machine next to our dishwasher machine
thank you I agree dude like some of the
or like uh or like have you ever noticed
how the inside of a refrigerator no
matter how rich you are it always looks
like [__] like we need like a better
organizer or something for like so some
of these like day-to-day problems I
think need to be improved particularly
we'll start with the washer and dryer it
needs to be one machine okay I like that
one Andrew
um so mine I tweeted about this
um so there's all these private jets out
there flying around all over the world
and uh tell me about it um people people
will people will fly somewhere and they
don't need a return flight or they're
gonna go there for two weeks or three
weeks or whatever and so the plane
actually flies back empty just with the
pilots on it right and I think this is
truly insane this is like billions of
dollars getting lit on fire every month
of just jet fuel and empty planes and
stuff I don't know what the solution is
I know there's people that have tried
this
um but it seems like a incredibly
inefficient disjointed uh world and
someone needs to crack this and create a
central database of basically every
plane that's available because let's
think about who owns private jets it's
very very rich people very rich people
are usually business people and are
logical do they care about having
someone else fly back if it pays for all
the fuel and stuff probably not maybe
like Gucci where it's like well I don't
want to like sell my unsold Gucci
clothes I'd rather just burn them to
keep the value up
sure yeah I don't know maybe but anyway
I do think there's a lot of people who
would certainly uh want to get
compensated for that if it was easy and
I think someone needs to crack this yeah
that's a that's a good one
um okay I'm gonna go with the school for
the starving artist okay so I've met a
lot of people in life who like to do
different artsy
things you know photography film uh you
know met somebody who was like you know
they like they're like oh yeah I fell in
love with photography because I would
hang up the freaking
prints and like let them dry like
whatever you know whatever that [__] is
uh you know coloring you know blah blah
drawing there's all these aren't
artistic things
and I would say most people give up on
those passions or things because it's
really really hard to make a living
doing it
or is it
that's what I want to answer because now
that I'm doing this Ecom thing I now pay
a lot of money to photographers it's
just that they had to be branded as
photographers who understand how to do
product photography or commercial photo
shoots
um my wife when she was in business
school was just doodling on her paper
board and somebody walked by and luckily
they saw that and they go did you draw
that and she was like oh yeah sorry uh
I'm paying attention I promise he's like
no no I don't care like but if you can
draw that I have a job for you it's
called graphic facilitation you can make
a thousand dollars a day
just by going to these meetings and
conferences for these businesses and you
draw on a giant whiteboard what they're
talking about so they have a visual
takeaway at the end of it and she made
more money than me for a long time doing
this thing she would have never known
how to turn her art into money and so I
think somebody should create an art
school for people who have artistic
talents but want to be rich uh for have
our discounts but they want to make a
living doing it and not just be a
starving artist for their whole life I
think you should create a specific
school for this and all the courses are
things where you take an artistic trait
but you teach them how to do it in the
commercial way and they can make money
even while they're in school doing this
like you know how big of a shortage
there is of video editors now that
YouTube and Tick Tock are so huge or you
know again commercial photography or
drawing or all these different different
uh artistic things so I think somebody
should create
the school for The Starving Artists
where they're no they're not going to
starve anymore and uh get the get the
artists that are willing to sell out
like 25 and just like do this like you
see this girl on Tick Tock she does
these she'll take like a uh like Dr
Pepper will pay her like
a million dollars to this Tick Tock
where she does these like crazy slo-mo
zoom in water dripping on the side and
she makes this epic like like video
trailer of a Dr Pepper she makes a Dr
Pepper look like it's the unveiling of a
new you know rocket by SpaceX and she's
just really talented at that and brands
are willing to pay her for that type of
marketing
yeah there's a lot of people out there
who could do that they just didn't
connect the dots well what are you gonna
call it you gotta have some cute ass
names don't have it yet that's the only
whole that's the only hold up I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna start until I have
the perfect name you know me
do we uh Andrew you look like you just
got your first communion uh you just
like you you have you haven't an Angelic
face and an Angelic look it doesn't
matter how rich and successful you
become you uh you still look like this
little perfect communion boy
thank you I'm working on becoming a
Twilight vampire like uh Brian that's my
other goal this year what's the thing he
eats every morning the piggy pudding or
whatever
yeah nutty pudding that's your face
looks more trim
oh thank you I feel like you say that
every time I come on just like a crazy
tan
have you just ever come back like in
Puerto Rican
um
my problem is I I tan really really well
on my arms and face but I'm like I
cannot Tan on my body so I have a have
you ever done a favor have you tried
taking off your shirt
uh no this is yeah sure I should do that
yeah and I want you to look like you
know Ricky Martin so you know just like
you need to come back at least like a
third Colombian in your tan next year
next time okay here's here's the deal
here's the deal okay you and I'm serious
you get to uh eight percent body fat I
will go to a tanning salon I will go in
one of those stand-up Tanners and I will
uh I will get really tanned and come on
you got a deal okay well no no it's
crazy 12 12 is like 12 is like soft ABS
I want like crazy shreds he'll look
shredded because he's dark
for like 12 minutes I'm gonna have to
like sacrifice my life to do this I
think 12 is a more than fair deal okay
this is a deal what's the what's the
timeline within the year whenever I do
it this is a lifelong bet if I ever get
there if I ever send you a picture Sam
we should
we got to talk about that Meetup we're
doing in Vancouver I will we'll do a
shout out next time at the beginning but
we'll also do it now so we're doing a
meet-up Sean obviously you're invited
but I don't ever I doubt you'll ever you
guys know me so well that you didn't
even invite me that's I appreciate that
you know me that well
yeah we're doing a meet up we have to
pick a date but it's going to be
mid-February in Vancouver right
how many people how many people signed
up or like gave interest I think it's we
already have we already have 600 people
so it's gonna be a big event we gotta
figure that out yeah we have to pick a
venue we just put it Andrew put a tight
for him he didn't even ask me he put a
type for him and he said uh Sam and I
are doing a meet-up sometime in February
TBD on all the details sign up here
that's pretty cool I'll go I'll I'll do
it you got people there's people on it
you want to come yeah come it'd be
awesome I think sahil said he would come
too and I just followed up with him on
Twitter I don't know if he's responded
but we got to get sahil out we I've got
some doctor's appointments in February I
got to work around so let me figure out
what when those are and then we'll pick
a date
all right guys well another successful
Millie Awards of the books thank you and
we will see you next year
[Music]